If you need to make changes to IP
addresses or configurations of your
network adapter inside of Linux, then
you'll need to use the IP command. From
here, you can enable an interface,
disable an interface, or make changes to
the configuration of your network
settings. To view your current IP
configuration, you can use the IP
address command. This shows you a
breakdown of IP addresses separated by
the interfaces inside of your Linux
device. If you want to view routing
tables, you can use IP route. And if you
need to configure an IP address on an
interface, there's a single command line
for IP address and then the parameters
that you'd like to update.
It's always a challenge when you sit
down at a new computer and you're not
quite sure what the IP address
configuration is of this device. So, on
this Linux machine, we will use the IP
address command and it shows us that
there are two separate interfaces on
this device.
Interface one is a loopback address and
it shows all the loopback address
information. Since this is a loopback
address, it will always have an address
on the 127 network and the default IP
address for most devices is 127.0.0.1.
There's also a second address. This is
the primary Ethernet adapter on this
device. This is adapter ENP0S5
and it has an IP address of 10.211.55.20
with a subnet mask of /24.
The broadcast address is 10.211.55.255
and you can view MAC information here.
There's also IPv6 information displayed
as well. If there are multiple adapters
inside of this computer, we will see the
IP address configuration for each of
those by running the IP address command.
If you're a system administrator of
other operating systems, then you're
probably already familiar with the ping
command. Ping command is an almost
universal command that's used across
many different operating systems to be
able to query a device across the
network and see if you can get a
response. This is usually one of the
first things you do when you're
troubleshooting the network. You use the
ping command to see if you can get a
response from that remote device.
The syntax of the ping command is very
similar to almost any other operating
system. We type ping and then we specify
an IP address that we would like to
access. Let's say in this case that we
would like to see if device 9.9.9.9
is going to respond to us across the
internet. That is for the quad 9 DNS
service. And if we hit enter, it begins
the process of pinging quad 9. It sends
56 bytes of data by default. We get
information saying that we are receiving
responses from that device. We can see
sequence numbers, time to live
information, and round trip time for
this ping.
Unlike other operating systems, you'll
notice that the ping command in Linux
will continue to ping every second until
you use the control C command and
interrupt the process. At that point, it
gives us a summary saying that we've
sent 26 packets, that we've also
received 26 packets. There's been zero
packet loss because of that, and this
occurred over time frame of 25,000
milliseconds, which is 25 seconds. The
round trip time minimums, averages,
maximums, and deviations
are also listed at the bottom. You can
see that our minimum time was 35
milliseconds, the average was 35, the
maximum was 36.8,
and we have a standard deviation of
0.450
milliseconds.
When you're working at the command line,
there's obviously no graphical browser
that you can use to access a website,
but there are ways to request and
receive information from a web server
using HTML at the command prompt and the
utility curl. Curl stands for client
URL, and we're able to data from that
device using a specific uniform resource
locator. This allows us to access a
webpage or even other devices using this
curl utility. Once we receive all of the
raw data or the raw HTML from that
website, you can then search through
that information, parse out any details,
or even use this as part of an automated
script.
If you're using a graphical browser, you
can specify a website like www.
www.professormesser.com
and you can view the information
associated with that website. But at the
command prompt, there is no graphical
browser, so we will use the curl command
and I will specify
www.professormesser.com
and the information that we receive in
the terminal screen is the raw HTML that
would normally be rendered by your
graphical browser. But since we have
access now to the raw HTML, we can
search through this data, we can parse
information, we can look and see what
may be really being transferred across
the network, and this shows us a raw
data view of the entire webpage.
When you're troubleshooting network
problems, you might also be
troubleshooting issues communicating to
a DNS server. One way that you can run
commands to see what type of response
you would get from that DNS server is to
use the dig utility. If you're a Windows
user, then you're probably familiar with
nslookup. The dig command is very
similar to the functionality of
nslookup, although the resulting output
is slightly different.
Let's use dig to find the IP addresses
associated with my website. We'll use
the dig command and then we'll specify
www.professormesser.com
and we'll hit enter. And when we do
that, it gives us a series of output
messages associated with our request.
The first is the dig version that we're
using and you can see that we're using
this to find www.professormesser.com.
It tells us that the request that we
made or the question that was posed was
for that fully qualified domain name,
and by default, I was asking for the
internet address. That's the IN and the
A associated with that question. The
next section is the answer section, and
you can see that there are three
separate IP addresses that were returned
from the DNS server. professormesser.com
can be found at 104.22.72.108,
172.67.41.114,
and 104.22.73.108.
By design, there are multiple points of
presence on the internet that will allow
you to connect to our web server. So,
depending on where you are in the world,
you may have a different IP address. And
occasionally, you will see more than one
IP address resolve to a single fully
qualified domain name, and that's
provided for redundancy. If you're not
able to connect to the first IP address,
there are two other IP addresses that
will get you to www.professormesser.com.
Earlier, we were able to ping the Quad9
DNS server across the internet. To be
able to communicate to that server, we
had to hop through a number of different
routers between my device and the Quad9
servers. If you would like to see every
router that exists between here and that
Quad9 server, you can use the traceroute
command. This will map the entire path
that a packet takes between our device
and that remote location, and tell us
the IP address of every router along the
way. If you're a Windows user, you've
probably run a traceroute using tracert,
but if you're in Linux, Unix, or macOS,
you use the full name of traceroute.
Traceroute uses something called a time
to live exceeded message to be able to
build this table of different routers
between two points. When we want to know
what the first router is, traceroute
uses a time to live of one. When we want
to know what the second hop might be, it
uses a time to live of two. Notice that
the time to live is referring to the
number of hops. It's not referring to a
time of day or the number of minutes or
seconds that it takes to communicate
across the network. Another challenge
you'll run into is that many devices
will filter the time to live exceeded
messages that are received back. So, if
you're working with a firewall that
filters out those ICMP messages or the
router itself that you're communicating
with will not send back a time exceeded
message, then that is a piece of
information that will be dropped from
the traceroute results.
Let's run a traceroute to my web server.
So, we'll run traceroute
www.professormesser.com
and we'll have it go through the
traceroute process. This will run
relatively quickly, although you'll
notice that there are certain hops along
the way where we do not receive a
message back from that router.
Specifically, we did lose two of those
messages on hop three and we didn't get
any information from hop five. If we
look at the results of this traceroute,
we can see there are 10 hops between our
device and the IP address associated
with www.professormesser.com.
In this case, it has found that IP
address to be 104.22.73.108.
And since we have a number of different
points of presence around the world,
that IP address might change depending
on where you happen to be. In each one
of these hops, you'll notice there is an
IP address. That's the IP address of the
router at that hop. And then there are
three separate measurements. These are
round-trip time measurements to that
particular router. By default,
traceroute performs each check three
times to every hop. You can, of course,
modify these configuration options
within the traceroute command line, but
by default, this gives you the overview
of what you might need to be able to
determine how many routers that might be
between one device and another.
If you've downloaded Linux to use on
your own system, then you already know
the download did not include any type of
separate documentation. Instead, the
documentation that you need for Linux is
built into the operating system itself.
And to access those manuals, you would
use the man command. Simply use man and
the name of the command that you would
like to reference and it will provide
all of the documentation for that
particular command.
For example, we just ran the traceroute
command, but there must have been other
parameters that we could have chosen and
we can find those by typing the man
option and the name of the utility. In
this case, it's traceroute and when we
hit enter, it shows us the reference
manual for traceroute, tracing the route
to a host. It shows all of the different
command line options and if I use an
arrow down, I can go a line at a time or
if I use the space bar, I can go a page
at a time. You can also use the arrow
keys or the page up and page down to
move back and forth through the manual
information.
For instance, you could have used the
\dash}f command to specify the first hop
of traceroute. You can choose the
method, the port number that's being
used. Remember earlier when I mentioned
that traceroute goes through each
individual hop three times. You can
modify that number with the \dash}q
option and you have information here
that can change the way the output is
shown on the traceroute command. When
you're finished reading through the man
page, it tells you that you can press h
for help or q to quit and since we're
done, we press q and we're back to where
we started.
The term concatenate means to link
together in a series and there is a
concatenate command inside of Linux and
it is abbreviated to cat. The cat
command allows you to view information
in a file and put that information on
the screen, or you could also take
multiple files and then move them into a
third file using a redirect such as the
greater than sign. Let's try that at our
prompt on our Linux machine.
On our Linux device, we have three
files, 1.text, 2.text, and 3.text. And
if we cat 1.text, you'll see that it
simply contains the number one and the
letters spelled out one, o w n. If we
cat 2.text,
it has a similar output, has the number
two and then spelled out the word two.
And then if we cat 3.text, it has the
number three and it spells out the word
three. We might want to have all of this
information in one single file. So, we
can use the cat command and then specify
1.text,
2.text,
and 3.text, and then use the greater
than sign to concatenate all of these
into all.text,
and we'll hit enter. Notice we simply
get a prompt back, meaning that this
particular concatenation is complete.
Now, if we cat all.txt,
you'll notice it is a single file that
contains the number one, one,
number two with two, and number three
with three. We have successfully
concatenated all three of those files
into one single file.
We're often called on as technicians to
troubleshoot performance problems on a
device. If you're on Windows, you
probably use task manager to view the
CPU utilization or disk access to a
particular system, or maybe you want to
see just how much network traffic is
being transferred. If you're a Windows
administrator, then you've probably used
Windows task manager to be able to view
CPU information or information on how
each individual process is performing.
There's a similar function within Linux
known as top. This will show you
information on all of the processes
running on your system and how much CPU,
memory, and other resources each process
may be using.
You also get a summary of the load on
your system presented as three separate
numbers. The first number is the load
over 1 minute, the second is the load
over the last 5 minutes, and the third
is the load over the last 15 minutes.
This is another one of those utilities
that has many different options
available to it. So, if you want to
customize top to provide information
that you'd like to see, make sure you
check out the man pages for the top
utility.
Running top is as simple as typing t o p
and hitting enter. And now we can see a
1-second update of what's running on our
system. We can view information by user,
the process ID, looking at memory
information, CPU details, and how much
time each individual process has spent
in the CPU. This gives us immediate
feedback on what's happening inside of
our system, and we're able to narrow
down what processes may be using more
resources than another.
If you would prefer a single text-based
output of all of these processes, you
can view that using the PS command. This
is also very similar to what you would
find in the Windows Task Manager because
it will list out all of the process IDs
and then all of the process names
themselves. If you just want to see the
processes associated with your login,
you simply use the PS command. But as
the administrator, you might want to
view all of the processes running on
this machine, and you can use the PS
with the \dash} e option to view all
processes.
If you run the PS command by itself,
you're only looking at the processes for
the current logged-in user. And I have a
bash shell, that is the terminal screen
that I have up, and I ran the PS command
inside of that bash shell. If we use the
PS command with the \dash} e, we're now
viewing the processes for everything on
the system and you can see there are
pages and pages of processes. You can
also pipe this output to the more
command which will paginate this so you
can go a page at a time to see all of
the processes without them going by all
at once. But if you're looking for a
very specific process, you might want to
use the PS command with the dash e and
then pipe it to the grep command and
then specify a search term. In this
case, let's look for all of the
processes that have the search term CPU
as part of the process. And you can see
that we have four that showed up. There
was process 20 which is CPUHP/0,
process 21 which is CPUHP/1,
and you can see two other processes that
have the word CPU as part of the process
name.
If you're like me, you probably don't
have a lot of free drive space on your
computer. And if you're planning to
perform an update or you want to install
a new application, it might be good to
see if you have enough space to be able
to perform that function. In Linux, the
way that we view this is with the DF
command. That stands for disk free. It
will show us all the file systems and
how much space might be available on
each file system.
The default is to use DF with no
parameters and this shows us the usage
based on number of blocks. In this case,
1K blocks. If you'd like a view that
showed it as number of bytes, you could
use the same DF command with a dash h to
get a human readable view. This will
show the output with gigabytes,
megabytes, and other human readable
values.
Let's run the DF command on my machine.
I'm going to specify dash h because I
like to see this listed as megabytes,
gigabytes, and other familiar values.
You can see that I have a number of file
systems that are mounted on this
computer. I have one that is a temporary
file system. It has a size of 196
megabytes. I'm only using 1.7 megabytes
so that 194 megabytes are available,
which means I'm only using 1% of my temp
FS file space. I have other things that
are connected to this computer. For
example, I have T4 volume 3. This has a
volume size of 3.7 terabytes. I'm using
1.9 terabytes, which means that 1.8
terabytes is available, so I'm using
approximately 52% of that particular
file system. So, if we need to install
some additional software, we might want
to avoid file systems with over 90%
utilization and instead use one of these
file systems that has much more space
available.
The natural next question when you find
a file system that has very little space
available is what is taking up all of
that room on the file system? It may be
a single file, it may be multiple files,
but we need to determine how we might be
able to free up some space on that
particular partition. One way that you
could find out what's using that space
is by using the du command for disk
usage. This will scan your current
folder and all of the subdirectories
underneath, and it will show you exactly
how much space is being used in each
individual folder. If you're looking to
find how you can easily free up some
space, this utility should be the one
you run. And I would recommend running
it with the dash H option so that you
get human readable output.
I'm going to run the du command with
that dash H option, and I'm going to
pipe the whole thing to more so that you
can get an idea of just how much
information is shown to the screen. And
it starts going through the local
directory and finding all of the files
that are stored in that local directory.
This starts going through all of the
individual directories on a particular
system one by one and provides you with
a summary of how much space is being
used. Let's hit the spacebar to go to
the next page. Almost everything here is
a relatively small number. Here's one
that's relatively large, it's 1.4
megabytes. We have others that are 12
megabytes, these are 28 megabytes. So
now we can start getting an idea of
where the space is really being used and
we might want to go to the old Firefox
data that is in our directory that's
taking up 70 megabytes and start
deleting those directories to free up
some room.
A lot of the configurations in Linux are
stored in text files. And if you need to
modify or change an application or
something in the operating system, you
need to modify that text file.
Fortunately, Linux comes with a number
of different text editors. One of the
more popular is Nano. This is a
full-screen text editor and you can run
it in your terminal screen. You may find
that Nano is already installed in your
current Linux distribution or you can
install it using the package manager on
your system. This full-screen text
editor allows us to use functions that
normally would not be available at the
command line such as marking and
selecting, copying information, pasting
it somewhere else, and giving us
features that you would normally find in
a graphical text editor.
On my Linux distribution, I have a file
that I would like to edit. This is the
auth.log file. You can see it's 27K in
length. This would not be something that
would be very easy to update or modify
without some type of editor. So we'll
use Nano and we'll specify auth.log.
This brings up a full-screen editor and
if you've done any type of editing from
a graphical editor or full-screen in
Linux, this should be very familiar to
you. You can move around with your
cursor keys, you can type in at any of
these prompts, and you have commands
across the bottom where you can save the
file, get additional help, copy, cut,
replace, and perform other functions
inside of this text editor. When you're
done, you can choose the control X
option to exit out. Since I've made
changes to this file, it asked if I'd
like to save this information. In this
case, since I did not put anything in
here that I'd like to save, I'll simply
choose no and we're back at our command
prompt. Nano is just one of many text
editors that you could run inside of
your Linux operating system, but since
Nano is commonly installed with most
distributions, it's probably already
going to be available to you.